[Music]
um
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
check it out
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
move it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ten
[Music]
[Music]
ten
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
video games are a remarkable way to both
tell and experience stories they invite
you to enter worlds of action
fantasy terror and wonder not just a
member of the audience
but an active participant they are
stories that are shaped not only by the
visions of their creators but by the
choices you make as they unfold
they are changed by you just as you were
changed
by them this year for the first time
tribeca has selected eight games
we hope they offer you a brief glimpse
into the
ingenuity and artistic scope that games
have to offer the world
and why they belong at the forefront of
our conversations about storytelling
both now and in the future we can't wait
for you to play them
horror stories are often about the thing
or deepest fears and anxieties made real
in the form of ghosts ghouls and demons
but in the survival horror game signals
the true horror lies not in the
shambling monsters
you find lurking in a subterranean
bunker
or an alien planet but in what lies
beyond the limits of human comprehension
revelations so dreadfully that can
shatter the mind
this is the cosmic horror of signals
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ah
noise
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
after action
[Music]
actually
[Music]
huh
[Applause]
spirits is a rich compelling tale of
fantasy and adventure with themes of
trauma and loss of forgiveness and yes
it's full of fast-paced action and
breathless battles with supernatural
foes
but the first thing that hits you when
you see it is the beauty of a debut game
from a small but passionate team at
ember labs
and how the stunning animation of its
lush magical world pulls you into a
journey
of a spirit guide trying to save a
village haunted by restless souls
but why not let you see it for yourself
here's our next official selection
cana bridge of spirits
[ __ ] penny ground yourself
feel the energy of the mountain
[Music]
draw on its power
[Music]
[Music]
the emblem is a really small studio we
have a background in
film and animation uh we got our start
doing visual effects for
films
[Music]
and then from there we go into doing a
lot of animated work for commercials
[Music]
in between commercial projects we would
always siphon off some time to learn new
things and you know be a little creative
and over time you know we decided that
wow we have a real passion for games
um and we wanted to throw our hat into
the ring with our first project kanan
something tells me you did not come to
our village looking for forest creatures
hello spirit i seek passage to the
sacred mountain shrine
we've been playing games our whole lives
together as brothers
and the action-adventure games are sort
of what we play together and we also
enjoy
[Music]
we kind of had this idea of the rot
being kind of a force of nature that was
maybe working against you it was kind of
the enemy initially and then i kind of
had the
uh thought to flip it where the robbie
would become your companions
[Music]
and that's when we kind of like found
that we we had something kind of unique
i opened a lot of cool mechanics
especially with the puzzles in the game
[Music]
you know with film you can just put the
camera where you want it you can tell
you can you have complete control over
what they're seeing when they're seeing
it how they're seeing it
in games all that goes out the window so
communicating
ideas or themes to the player is a lot
more difficult we found yeah
you have to be really sort of crafty in
how you're getting communication to the
player
um especially when it's trying to do it
through gameplay and not just like
always through cutscene
one of tara's memories i should see what
leads me
we love creating immersive experiences
and we tried to really
think about atmosphere and tone a lot
when we're when we're in on the game
development side
storytelling and atmosphere is a big
part of our
traditional medium sort of film
aesthetics just having the world be
something you want to sit down and
explore and be a part of
um was a goal of ours from the beginning
having a nice team of really great
animators who have worked together i
think was paramount in terms of pulling
off some of the
storytelling we want to do with the game
[Music]
we're actually making like a 45 minute
animated
movie inside of a game hi i'm really
proud of the team
a lot of them come from the visual
faction animation background and kind of
like convert their skill sets from
the film and animation background into
developers on the game side
during the process of making the game we
also were introduced to
the musical group called sudamani and we
actually you know jason and myself went
over to bali to do
recording for the soundtrack
[Music]
one of the things that's grown out of
that relationship is uh day wise
it's the composer but his daughter iu is
actually the voice of kana
my name's kayna what are you two doing
out here
she's never done any voice acting but
she fit right in it's okay
you have to go now
you know we wanted to make a game that
would just excite us if we saw it you
know something that we would see the
channel oh yeah that's that game
was awesome yeah so as difficult as as
it has been
it's also very rewarding because it's
like something that we would
very proud of something we would want to
pick up ourselves you must move on
uh
the path of a spirit guide is a lonely
one
southern gothic is a uniquely american
storytelling tradition
blending magical realism with dark tales
of decay in the american south
norco adds a dash of sci-fi to the
southern gothic stew
moving cyborgs and artificial
intelligence
into pixelated louisiana landscapes
where the sun sets heavy and orange over
the swamps
and all refineries blaze like torches in
the night
it is a place where people memories and
secrets
have a way of getting lost and buried
dig them up if you dare
in the haunting and extraordinary
adventure that is norgo
[Music]
geography of robots is a handful of devs
artists and musicians making output that
is largely centered around the american
south
and the psycho geography of the american
south
another one
[Music]
our first release is a game called norco
which is about my hometown of norco
louisiana
[Music]
a small very industrialized town about
25 miles upriver from new orleans
[Music]
there's so many intersecting pieces of
infrastructure
so many stories embedded in the
landscape
[Music]
i've been fascinated with that region
since i was a kid
i wanted to synthesize all of those
research interests into something and
norco is that
culmination of effort
it draws from both reality and
certain sci-fi tropes
[Music]
to explore little air pockets of the
surreal
within the reality of the game
[Laughter]
the primary benefit that we have working
in this sort of adventure game
point-and-click genre is that we've got
just
decades and decades of iteration to
build on within the genre going back to
the old
lucas games you know monkey island and
such
what works for our story what are the
necessary mechanics
to tell the story of norco
[Music]
i was interrogating a lot of
events and experiences from the past
i was playing a lot of 2d pixel art
games at the time
a lot of traumatic events had occurred
both in my
personal life and the life of the region
that i was exploring
and i thought there was a kind of
ontological element
to using pixel art to tell those stories
[Music]
i don't have any artistic experience and
so doing a simple
2d pixel art game fit the best within my
limited
resources that i had
[Music]
in the more recent years big and small
studios have really been uh
pushing like what it means for
player agency to take a front seat in a
semi-linear narrative
[Music]
it has been an interesting journey
pushing the boundaries of the medium
and kind of forcing it into this
more complex uncomfortable future
in the handmade adventure game harold
halibut a spaceship full of people
fleeing the cold war crash lands
in an alien ocean where the sunken ship
becomes a city that's forever stuck in
the 1970s
and when i say handmade adventure game i
mean that in a very physical tangible
way
every set every character every
floorboard and every coffee cup has been
meticulously handcrafted from wood
clay cloth and metal to bring this
gorgeous world to life
i'm pleased to introduce the stop motion
adventure
harold halibut
[Music]
hi we are slow brothers a tiny
interdisciplinary game studio based in
cologne germany
hey world stop daydreaming and don't
forget to fix the light after cleaning
up the paint
sometimes i do wonder what life would
have been like on earth
it's been about 10 years since we
started game development
some of us have a film background and at
that time we were kind of frustrated
about the
big budgets needed to produce a
feature-length film
the dependencies to producers
being also game lovers we thought that
making a game instead of a film to tell
a story
might be the more approachable endeavor
we quickly realized that the budgeting
thing at least wasn't too different from
feature-length films but
we were way too deep into the process
already
of when when we realized that
our goal has always been to create a
accurate recreation of of a stop-motion
film to create a cinematic feel
and our initial approach was
quite a lot of experimentation involved
until we found
our process that we use now which is
street scanning everything by using
photogrammetry
to create 3d models of the characters
that we then animate
using motion capturing
which gave us this fluidity and also all
the
options that we have in modern 3d games
to light
the scenes in a cinematic way and to use
camera movement
so uh it's it's even a little bit
different than
you know traditional stop-motion
animation and we
really liked this mix of the digital
world and the analog world
[Music]
we've heard a bunch of people
questioning why we put
such effort into building the sets and
the tiny details
ultimately we think that's why the game
feels the way it does
is because of the sum of its parts and
that level of detail coming together as
like a
greater thing we just like put a lot of
effort into
giving the individual characters and
harold's
social environment a lot of debts and
that
ultimately makes for like a rich
experience
now if you're quite ready sure i'm
ready for what i made a breakthrough
discovery at the arboretum last night
you remember the last batch of bloomy
rocks oh the really small ones from the
last intake
the ones with the strange shapes and the
little holes and
the blue ones yes turns out their
surface composition
doesn't just give us clues about our
immediate aquatic environs
i think they've picked up some
influences from outer space as well
we create a relatable science fiction
world
instead of having a super distant sci-fi
future where things are so different
that it might as well be magic it may
have started with one man
but it took the hearts and minds of many
more to make the dream a reality
that dream began at the height of the
cold war when the world was on the very
brink of annihilation
he conceived of an ark-like space-faring
ship
after 200 years we finally arrived at
our destination
only to find that the promising watery
planet contain
no habitable landmass and dense toxic
gases in the atmosphere
the cold war seemed like a good starting
point
for the backstory of our game and it
enabled
us to have this kind of weird mix
of being stuck in the 70s on one hand
and
not living through the things we all
know in our
presence but also thinking into the
future
the 200 years after that um and creating
this
kind of alternative timeline
where things evolved in a different way
it's just that
the professor and i need some sea rocks
i mean
filter rocks from older times that have
come
from the filters and i feel like you
might have one
okay look and listen here longy long
pants i shut the store for a reason you
know
while we have this overarching storyline
in our game
with multiple story arcs harold is only
one part of this
bigger story and we always kind of focus
on harold's personal interactions
relationships and friendships of
herald harold good timing you can
explain things to the major can't you
harold come here and explain things so
harry
how's life been treating you you know
keeping fishy
what you know keeping busy okay
harold is everything okay
and therefore really concentrated on
providing
a lot of depth in those characters for
players to ultimately explore
harold won't you stay the jog team won't
be the same without you
yeah wenger hurdle you can't leave now i
just got here
dog team dog team jog team
go jog team come on harold
keep up deep breaths harold you're doing
great
guys have you got any tips just
keep on moving harold you never know
when you'll have to slow down
so keep going while you can
yeah that is so cute
[Music]
imagine setting off across a vast desert
on a rite of passage
with no one to share the long and lonely
trip but your trusty hoverbike
on your journey to the horizon you will
traverse a world of beauty
and mystery full of spectacular ruins
both ancient and futuristic
this is the joy of exploration the
thrill of discovery
and if you listen to the stories of the
people and places you encounter
perhaps a chance to learn what you came
here to understand
this is sable
[Music]
shed works is us i'm greg
this is daniel and we started out with
my parents [ __ ]
[Music]
sable is the main character she's a
young girl
who's leaving her home for the first
time
the gliding is what sable embarks on as
the story starts and it's something that
everybody who comes of age in the world
of sable
does it's how you find out what you want
to become in life
leaving your home behind and
experiencing the world meeting people
trying things helping folks in need and
ultimately deciding
what do i want to devote my life to
[Music]
so much of the people here the
communities here are defined by their
vocation
you know the desert that they live in is
inhospitable and so they kind of had to
come together
and had to form groups around resources
and so sable kind of goes
from place to place meeting different
societies and cultures
built around completely different
experiences
of the same environment
it means that she has to be a sponge
right she's trying to figure out
her place in the world what she wants to
do for the rest of her days
and i think that's what makes the story
so fun it really is about the places
that you go the people that you see
and the experiences that you have that
not only shape
her gliding but shape her
[Music]
my dad and danny's dad went to
architecture school together
you know our lives have kind of crossed
a bit in that period
your mum taught me our secondary school
by the time we were sort of university
age that was when indie games had really
kind of taken off as a
creative sort of field i started to
think that
that was something that i could paint
myself
i studied architecture daniel studied
comparative digital
but neither of us had any experience
making games
before we started making games
we kind of went to the pub one time
and had a chat about how we
because we had none of these industry
direct connections to skills or
experience we thought
we'd start our own internship do our own
internship
in the in the chef the initial thought
was just
let's get some experience on firebelt
and see where we go from there
somehow six years or so later
we're here now still going
[Music]
the thing that we've really tried to
focus on is exploration
and we kind of geared every design
decision
that we could around that focus
there's no real danger to the player in
the game
it is quite relaxing in a way but that
doesn't make it less
curious a world to explore it
i think the unique thing about it is how
lonely it is
and the pace of the game is very laid
back
[Music]
it was the first game that we designed
that was really geared around
our skills as well our backgrounds we
wanted to do something narrative focused
uh
maybe your background in comparison
literature to architectural
architecturally focused and my
background architecture help with that
so
i think that it's come from us
in that way makes it quite unique
we draw from a number of references and
influences i suppose
i guess some of the most obvious ones
are the
visual ones right stuff like mobius or
um or tintin
or studio ghibli and
you know those kind of pieces were
always
influential
yeah it does have that mix of ancient
and futuristic to our eyes right
who live here but to the eyes of sable
and to everyone
in that world that is all that they know
[Music]
we brought a new breakfast onto the
project really early on right before we
really
started it and so our music has kind of
been there from the very beginnings but
that's been the music itself has been a
really big part of
shaping shaping weather the direction of
the game
[Music]
it feels like
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the gothic fairy tale lost in random
the world is divided into six shadowy
realms
where every citizen's fate is determined
by the role of a cursed eye
you play as even a young girl who's set
out on a quest to save her beloved
sister odd
and with the help of your companion a
magical living guy named dicey
you'll find yourself battling your way
through a dark wonderland
and if you want to win the game you'll
have to embrace the chaos
and find a way to tip the odds in your
favor from the odd
and even minds of zonk games here is
lost in random
[Music]
so lost in random is being developed
here at sewing games in gothenburg
sweden we're about 80 developers with a
few different projects
but boston random is definitely our
biggest and most ambitious project
ever
we're known for doing quite narrative
driven games we really want to make
games that speak to people and touch
people
and make people think
[Music]
lost in random is a 3d action adventure
game set in the gorgeous
gothic fairy tale world of random and it
tells the tale of even a young girl who
befriends
dicey a living dice with incredible
powers
even goes on this journey to rescue her
sister from the clutches of a mad queen
who's obsessed with board games
and so the queen decreed that any child
who had turned the age of 12 would be
given the grand honor of rolling her one
true dice
to show them their place in the world of
random for random is fair
random prevails and random
random
rules
even she's this naive young kid who's
just
for the first time going out into the
world to find out who she is
it's really a story about the randomness
of life and conquering
the fear of it
[Music]
even and dicey are a really fun duke
even is this quick to anger but she's
not one to hold grudges but she can
easily get into a fight
and dice is there to hold her back
[Music]
daisy who is this cute puppet kind of
character
his moment to shyness is when you're in
combat
when even rolls dicey he becomes this
kind of swiss army knife
of magical power
no dicey they should be scared of us
right we're really in love with this
project
it's a great story it's great actors
it's the innovative game play and
it just feels like everything is just so
perfectly packaged together around the
dice
and this universe and the style of the
game is kind of like something out of a
leica or
tim burton movie it's really everything
we've dreamt of doing
all these years it's really great and we
can't wait
for everybody to play it
[Music]
in the interactive thriller 12 minutes
you play as a man who becomes trapped in
a time loop
replaying the same 12 minutes of one
fateful evening in his apartment over
and over again each time you're going to
have the chance to make new choices
learn what led up to those terrible
events and perhaps even escape them
it's a story that's not just about how
choices matter but about how some
stories can only truly be told
when they can change even just a little
bit every single time you tell them
it was a joy to participate in this
project and lend my voice to the main
character and i hope you have as much
fun playing it as i did making it
i'm very proud to introduce a game where
the end is
only the beginning 12 minutes
i have a surprise for you okay
you want to guess what it is this is an
outfit for a newborn
you bought it this morning you wanted to
surprise me
i'm sorry you're pregnant you know
i know because you already gave it to me
this has happened before what are you
talking about
what's going on someone is coming he's
going to hurt us
he says you killed your father i need to
know what happened
why are you doing this my father died of
a heart attack
oh i i i didn't have anything to do with
any second now he's gonna knock on that
door help me
this isn't happening this can't be
happening
please open up
my name is luis i am the creator of 12
minutes
i grew up watching a lot of film they
always captivated me and i
tried to understand what were they doing
the the pacing the colors the lighting
the composition
in order to to create these emotions
what are the tools we have as game
designers that allow us to do similar
things
i think the biggest challenge is that
usually when we think about narrative
we think about a linear progression an
interactive game
at least in 12 minutes that information
can come
at any moment depending on what you've
done what's the occasion
i'll tell you of a dessert
all right i'm ready to get wowed by this
dessert just give me one second
you know i are fascinated by the idea of
if you knew what's going to happen
what would you do differently
12 minutes is an interactive thriller
about a man trapped in a time loop
you come home from work you're having an
evening with your wife then this is
this cop shows up he accuses your wife
of murder hands behind your back let's
go
you try to stop him you get beat up
only to wake up back to the start of the
evening
and then you have to use the knowledge
of what you know it's going to happen
to try to change the outcome and break
the loop look
i know this sounds weird but the day's
repeating itself
what do you mean repeating itself i'm
living the same chunk of time
over and over again uh-huh
the reason the game sticks to a bird's
eye view is because
it allows you to very easily interact
with the environment
most video games you have a third-person
camera or a first-person camera and i
wanted to create something that is
very accessible so by doing a bird's-eye
view you have like a floor plan
of the apartment that you just click
with the room
[Music]
there was also the challenge of having
the voices convey the emotions without
seeing the faces
if someone is really stressed out you
won't have any facial expressions so you
have to feel the stress in the throat
particularly because you don't see our
faces in it you really are
projecting whatever you're feeling onto
the character there's no facial
expressions that are instructing you
where you go in the game will i think
depend on you as an
an individual i just need some time to
myself
come on babe please stop it
and if there's enough subtlety in the
voice acting in the movement your brain
will feel the rest
because actors think in terms of
motivations you know what's my
motivation for this thing
and workshopping with them figuring
those things out allows
the characters to become alive and
become meaningful in the way they
they behave like i didn't mean to this
is never what i wanted
no come on i warned you look i you can't
do this
it will be different things for
different people there are so many
versions of the story that will either
reveal something or show something
and you as the player are revealing how
you deal with truth how you deal with
other people's truth
working in interactive medium you can
make a story that becomes very personal
to you
right you're not passively looking at
what's happening and processing you're
actually
deciding by allowing you to participate
to change it
to mold the way it's built in a way it
becomes part of you
it's like you're part of the creative
process that is happening and because
the game doesn't really give you a
direction
the decisions you make are based on who
you are
i'll prove it yeah great let's see it
wow me that allows you to
explore a side of yourself that maybe
you wouldn't otherwise
[Music]
silently repeat these phrases may you be
free from
suffering may you be free from fear
may you know peace and joy
[Music]
if you're not familiar with the big con
a coming-of-age comedy adventure about a
teen in the 1990s well
let me explain you play as ally a high
school junior
who learns that her mom is about to lose
her video rental store to loan sharks
unless they come up with over 90
000 asap well there's clearly only one
thing you can do
run away from band camp head to the mall
and become a con artist
i mean that's just common sense from the
decade they gave us the world wide web
and so so much plaid i give you
the big con
[Music]
[Music]
hey i'm dave proctor from ideal studios
and i am the game director
and writer on the big con
uh mighty yell is a company from toronto
we're made up of some
really really awesome devs from this
city george taking camps
saffron aurora tabby rose screen ideas
and yashkul kearny is our core team
the vidcon is a adventure game where you
hustle your way across 90s america
as a teenage con artist it's all for a
good cause you are trying to save your
mom's video store
so you learn to pickpocket where
disguises
talk your way into and out of trouble
all for that good not so good cause of
making sure your family business stays
at slope
you know one of the toughest things
about making this game was was selling
people on the on the non-violent crime
aspect of it um games with guns don't
bat an eye but
you know the moment you have to steal an
old lady's wallet people start to think
maybe there's something wrong with you
um which is fine
that's part of the fun of making this it
really helps us make something that you
know
challenges people and challenges
ourselves and
hopefully helps us find a little bit of
in between uh in a story like this
[Music]
ultimately ally's doing crimes for a
good cause and you know writing a
funny and heartfelt story kind of helps
justify those actions so
you know on the one hand we get to make
a game that we've never seen before
which is a conor video game and on the
other hand we get to kind of couch that
in a conversation about small businesses
surviving and
you know a story about a mother and a
daughter and between that and the 90s
really informed like what we were
capable of coming up with in terms of
this relationship like who is linda
ally's mom who raised her as a single
mom and kept a business together and
is tough as hell and what is that person
like and what is her daughter like how
do they play off against each other ally
can be you know
she can be a teenager she can be she can
be rough she can be sarcastic
this is something that we really wanted
to see and i think it brings a lot of
truth
to the game
[Music]
if it makes us laugh it goes in the game
that was our that was our rule like we
really want you to explore
and find stuff
[Music]
random conversations with people that
you know some people might see some
people might not
it makes us happy knowing that it's in
there
[Music]
and it i think really builds on the
feeling of like building your own
adventure
[Music]
the 90s are just not they're not as done
in video games we want to do it we want
to get in there
the 90s are a time when you don't have
cell phones you don't have the internet
you don't have the ability to look this
stuff up if you need to
and it makes it a little bit more
believable that you can be a traveling
con artist which i think is
part of the charm and so you know with
the 90s means that we also get to do
this
ribbon colorful palette that saffron put
together
i watched a lot of cartoons growing up
hey arnold doug and the simpsons
they sort of set the foundation for this
cartoon 90s aesthetic
bright contrasting colors exaggerated
features
and like fun geometric patterns so ali
is a very does what she
wants character she wears her cat
backwards
that to me was always the signature look
of the cool
leader type character that you'd see in
a lot of cartoons
you know she has the ripped jeans the
baggy t-shirt and she
also wears her plaid shirt wrapped
around her waist
which is you know a very i think 90s
style
the references from the burblows to
music or
grunge or um you know what movies were
popular and like
it just we don't want to we don't want
to beat you over the head with nostalgia
but we want to bring you there we want
you to be on this journey with us
the big con is the 90s crime adventure
you've been waiting for
what do you think rad ghost
okay i just want to finish off by saying
thank you so much
for the opportunity to be a part of this
um and to be
you know in the presence of such
incredible incredible games
uh and really just incredible
international talent um
means a lot to a pretty stoked team from
toronto
so we hope to see you there and
we may try to steal the award anyways
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you